dans notre grande enquête toujours est
ce que le français serviable est ce que
le français va accepter de porter une
jeune dame comme 80 lary qui fait
semblant de s'être foulé la cheville
est-ce qu'il va la porter jusqu'à sa
voiture la question est posée et bien
entendu dans l'ombre il y à jacques
legras qui veille
regardez bien ce sketch de la caméra
cachée tourner ces jours ci dans paris
là je prends pas mon cas c'est non et
c'est un jeu par saleh dans ma voiture
aulas
oui oui
c'est la quête de la vérité
c
et toi
je peux vous dire en particulier n'ont
pas stérile
une main portrait elle m'a demandé de
lui apporter comme ça d' effet je me
suis retrouvé sans mon portefeuille
vous avez toujours votre portefeuille
oui c'est sûr vous en assurer
à
mais qu'est ce que j'ai dit je dis
attention parce que quelqu'un toujours
les mêmes
collet laffon
ce départ manqué mais j'avais une partie
fallu quand même pas qu'on sait jamais
et d'avoir
ah ouais ouais on part dans les bras
à converger collector
pourquoi
j'ai plus
eh bien vous le voyez tous les hommes
acceptent de porter café alary mais tout
ça repose à terre quand on est l'autre
leur portefeuille en particulier parce
que les allemands fin trait comme ça et
peut donc y retrouver mon porteur
depuis toujours oui je vous êtes sûrs
c'est certain mais c'était pour la
caméra cachée vous savez j'ai filmé pour
la gamme et radiations
je peux vous dire qu'on veut dire un mot
parce que rien
hier elle m'a fait la même chose je me
suis retrouvé sans mon portefeuille
alors moi je vous conseille de la
laisser m oui hein si je me suis
retrouvé sans mon pas vous avez votre
portefeuille toujours un
oui vous avez de la chance parce qu'il
ya moi j'aime bien avant et oui mais il
est à vous mais demandez vous pas fait
aussi parfois par mois je vous connais
et puis quand j'ai fini de vous fier
j'avais plus mon portefeuille allez
prouver quelque chose
non mais vous verrez bien je sais qu'il
est nécessaire c'est certain pour les
femmes le conflit ossète lui apporter
madame comme ça tranquillement galopante
et pas désagréable
oui
une chose en particulier parce que elle
m'a fait une cour hier je me suis
retrouvé sur mon portefeuille
en particulier la même chose et vous
avez tout vu
c'est son problème
c
eric un oui massif
vous dire un moment particulier parce
qu'il y a
et puis je me suis informé sans mon
portefeuille
le problème n'est portée jacques n'osera
pas ça c'est mieux si vous pouviez me
porter
je suis comme ça dans la vie aussi mais
si j'ai des bons points séparent et la
voiture est là justement pour une tente
et sous préfets
mais bon
les matous réponse ça c'est préventif
est très gentil
avait lieu en france à 16
non non vous les jeux des jouets
qu'est ce que la rencontre ne suis pas
ici
ces hommes étaient prêts et pas vraiment
parce que celui très très dur de me
porter je fais un bon point quand même
d'un verre ça peut se faire mais c'est
difficile de même vous l'avais cru quand
elle est venue dans sa vie ce jeudi
parce que porter jacques legras voyez
vous n'allez pas y arriver